good morning and welcome to our webinar
I'm Julie Taylor from CDC and today I'm
going to tell you about how you can
improve health care with more effective
clinical laboratory tests utilization I
will share with you some information
today about our program at CDC called
clinical laboratory integration into
health care collaborative but don't
worry I'm not going to ask you to
memorize our title I just hope you'll
remember it as click today I'm going to
tell you about why we at CDC are
focusing on laboratory test utilization
I'm going to share with you some
information about our click program
including the vision that we have our
team members and also information on key
projects as you go through the talk
today you will see some slides that look
like this that have a question mark on
them at that point it will be a cue that
I'm going to ask you a question and to
pull you so look for this as I go
through the talk today and then we hope
to be able to share with you the answers
if you think about what was happening in
the 1970s we only had about 50
laboratory tests for doctors to use so
it wasn't that difficult for physicians
to know how to order test win the order
test and how to interpret the results
but if you fast-forward to today there
are over three thousand tests for
doctors to use and it can be quite
cumbersome for them to keep up with the
new lab tests that are coming out every
day as a matter of fact one physician
said Julie I have to work with patients
all day
them I visit with patients I spend my
time with patients all day long the
little time and I have outside of
patient care I focus on learning about
what is in my own area the new articles
in my own specialty I don't have time to
look at what is going on in the new lab
test area to keep up with new lab tests
and if you think about this we in the
lab I consider myself as a lab person we
have to keep up with these lab tests and
the new ones that are coming out and
it's a challenge for us so you can
imagine that a physician has trouble
also keeping up with the amount of new
tests that are coming out every day one
study that was done by shift at all
interviewed physicians and did a survey
of physicians and had him a report on
their own diagnostic errors and the
study published 583 physician reported
diagnostic errors and they found that
there were errors in the ordering
process all the way through the
interpretation of the lab test process
so we do have physician errors in the
laboratory testing area so we want to be
able to work on these to reduce them we
may say well what did that cause what
did that do did that cause any harm well
the study also asked these physicians
about their errors and unfortunately
they did report that the majority of
these errors caused some type of home
now forty-one percent of the errors were
viewed as moderate which means that they
caused a patient to stay in the hospital
maybe a little bit longer maybe they
ordered more tests than were necessary
but what was alarming was that
twenty-eight percent of these errors
were reported as men
which even included death so we do have
diagnostic errors that cause patient
harm another study found that under
utilization is more prevalent than
overutilization we think about the lab
that we want to reduce a number of
repeat test the way our system works we
are not very integrated so as a patient
you go from one position to another and
the new physician doesn't know that the
first physician had ordered a test so
they order the same test so you can have
the same test over and over again so
that's over utilization and we know that
we need to reduce that and our
electronic systems are going to be able
to help us with that but this study
reported that there is a problem with
under utilization and they also reported
that the true cost of laboratory testing
is downstream in that we have over
prescribed for patients we order
surgeries for patients when they aren't
needed and extended hospital stays what
the authors reported is that to reduce
errors and improve care you need to
improve initial test ordering also
clinical decision support tools could be
helpful and education in this study is
interesting because you'll see that
those three themes are the themes of
what I'm going to share with you today
about our click program so they also
said that improving laboratory
utilization should lead to more
effective and cost effective care this
gets to I click vision laboratory
medicine is fully integrated in the
health care system resulting in better
patient care and improve patient
outcomes our goal is to improve
laboratory test utilization to improve
the connection between the laboratory
professional and the clinician all for
the betterment of
patient care so we're trying to improve
these connections through our work would
click if you want to read more about
click I'll have several articles that
you will see the web address for during
my talk this is one of the ones I wanted
to share with you that was published in
clinical laboratory news in September
2012 and it was focused on our click
work so you can read more about our
project if you would like to go to the
web address that is listed at the bottom
of the slide and all of the articles i'm
going to share with you today are
available free on the internet we have a
work group to help us would click we're
very pleased that we have a group of
people that have been working with us
for several years now i mentioned that
our goal for click is to improve the
connection between the laboratory
professional and the clinician so to do
that we have set a workgroup up so that
we have representatives from both of
those groups we have a co-lead dr. John
hick nur there is a practicing family
physician at the University of Illinois
in Chicago who helps us with the
clinician side as you can imagine if we
were going to work on improving lab test
utilization and we in the lab would say
oh those physicians need to do this and
those physicians should do that that
won't help because the physician needs
to tell us what the issues are and help
us with how we can help them so dr. hick
nur is great at helping us with saying
oh we can't do that in our environment
we need to do it this way the other
co-lead that we have is dr. Michael la
posada who is a pathologist at
Vanderbilt University Hospital and he
helps us with the laboratory
professional side we also have other
great members of the work group who help
us with our project and as you see as I
go through the talk today you will see
their names because each one of them
lead their own projects for click here's
a picture from one of our work groups
that we had in Atlanta every year we
bring our work group together to talk to
them face-to-face about what we have
accomplished the year before and what we
would like to do for the next year i
also have a team at cdc to help us
beyond the external work group that i
just shared with you we have a group of
people at CDC dr. Nancy Cornish is a
medical officer with us at CDC and
[ __ ] who has been with click even
before click was around in that she
helped us initiate the work of click and
ran is an O rise fellow and Pam Thompson
is one who has helped us with almost
every project that I will share with you
today we also have a manager whose chief
of our branch dr barbs in Bauer who
helps us in support through management
today I'm going to share with you some
information about our key projects there
will be three projects i'll discuss
related to clinician test selection and
result interpretation i'll also share
with you a project that we have focused
in the area of medical student education
so to get started let me tell you about
the clinician tests election results
interpretation project the survey of
clinicians challenges we're very pleased
that this study has been published we
have worked to do a survey of clinicians
and we just recently got it published in
the Journal of American Board of family
medicine we were very pleased that we
were able to get the information in a
family medicine journal you think well
I'm working in the area of laboratory we
mostly published to our laboratory
audience but I mentioned we are trying
to make a connection between the
laboratory professional and family
matters
and primary care physicians and what
better way is to publish in their own
journal information thats related to
laboratory testing and help them with
how we can improve laboratory test
utilization you'll see at the bottom of
the screen I have the web address so
this is available for you for free at
the at this web address so if you're
interested in reading more than I'm
sharing with you today please go to that
online address and read more about the
article what we did is the goal was to
raise awareness about the challenges
clinicians phase for test ordering and
result interpretation I mentioned that
we had leads for the project that are
from our workgroup this project is led
by John hick nur and Paul Ethne we
worked on this project in two phases our
first phase is that we conducted focus
groups targeting family physicians of
internal medicine physicians so that we
learn from them what the issues were and
we use that information to go to Phase
two which was to design a national
survey of family physicians and internal
medicine physicians to get into some
more specifics about their challenges
here are the demographics
characteristics of the respondents and
the main thing I want to point out here
is these demographics are very similar
to the demographics of family physicians
in the United States so that our survey
is not biased in this manner as you see
I'm going to get to our whiteboard to
point out we have about equal numbers of
family medicine internal medicine and
family practice physicians and the age
is mostly between 45 and 60 years and we
have a little more male than female but
this is very similar to the demographics
that you find in the United States what
we ask physicians is how many times per
week do you see
patience and with those patients how
many times do you order diagnostic tests
and we found that they order tests in
about thirty one percent of their
patient encounters per week this was not
unusual because in the journal
literature there are reports that family
physicians order diagnostic tests about
one-third of the time so that was not
unusual but what was unusual and
alarming is that test ordering was and
they were uncertain in test ordering in
about fifteen percent of their patient
encounters and about half that they were
uncertain and how to interpret the
results with those tests that they use
for their patients we may think well
that maybe doesn't sound like very much
but if you calculate there are over 500
million primary care visits every year
and if one third of them are getting
laboratory tests ordered and fifteen
percent of the time physicians are
uncertain with ordering that could
impact about 23 million patients per
year so it does have implications for a
problem that we would like to address I
mentioned that we conducted a survey the
survey allowed physicians to write in
some comments so I'm going to share with
you some of the comments as we go
through the talk today but this one I
thought was very interesting the
question was when uncertain what
clinical lab tests to order for
diagnostic purposes how often do you one
physician answered look on wikipedia at
least once a week now we know that
wikipedia is not reviewed as a matter of
fact today I could post on Wikipedia the
way to improve laboratory test
utilization is to eat what I had for
lunch yesterday and unfortunately that
would be in Wicca
media and nobody would remove it it is
just the way the Wikipedia set up so it
was alarming to see that one position
thought that was a good answer I'm going
to go through the summary of the
findings with you today we're going to
talk about what they do to overcome
uncertainty what are some of the
challenges that they face in test
ordering and result interpretation and
methods for providing assistance before
we start I would like to pull you about
a question which method is used least
often by physicians I'm going to push
this poll out and give you a little bit
of time to answer i hope we will begin
to get some responses so let's see okay
we're getting some answers in i'll give
you a little bit more time since i think
we have time and did you just one more
minute till it seems to kind of calm
down great what we're going to do one
more okay i'm going to now think
everybody's just about finished anymore
ok we're going to close the poll and now
we're going to
push results there we go well yes many
of you know that ask a laboratory
professional is use the least so you
know the data from this slide one part
of the data let me get back to my
whiteboard and that is a skill a
professional was was voted on by the
clinicians as six percent so what I have
posted here on this slide is the results
of the survey where we asked them how
they overcome uncertainty and test
ordering and we gave them five choices
and i have only posted the top two
choices so for frequency it's at least
once a week or daily so six percent of
the physicians in the survey said that
they asked a lateral at least once a
week or daily helpfulness is plotted in
this graph from the most helpful on the
left to the least helpful on the right
so if you look at what was most helpful
to clinicians was curbside consult and
been reviewing references referred to a
specialist those were the most helpful
things that they did to overcome
uncertainty in test ordering now this is
a slide showing you the results when we
ask them how they overcome uncertainty
and results interpretation once again
most useful was from the left to the
right and it's follow up with the
patient was the most useful review
patient history with ue references and
refer to specialists were all things
that they found very very useful but I
would like to point out just like with
test selection
ask the lab professional was the least
that they do to when they are uncertain
with results interpretation and we know
being in the lab if you're in the lab
you know that if the physician were to
call you on the phone you could help
them but they do not think to do this so
what are their challenges there are two
different groups of challenges related
to test ordering cost factors are 1 and
this is percent of respondents who found
this very or extremely problematic
patient cost insurance policies limiting
things like the type of testing that can
be conducted lack of comparable cost
information there are studies that show
that if physicians see the cost of a lab
test when they are ordering they order
less of that test but I want to caution
you that we don't want to just post cost
without letting them understand when is
it important to order that test because
it may be more important to order the
test even though is it is an expensive
test ordering mechanisms are also a
challenge different test names for the
same test and they can't find the test
name in the test panels we have a
project on different test names that
I'll share with you in just a minute so
what are their challenges with result
interpretation receiving results was one
major category they look to the lab for
the drizzles they look for the lab for
the data they see us as lab data results
not received in a timely manner previous
results not easily available results are
inconsistent with patient symptoms we
found when we talk to physicians that if
the results are inconsistent with their
patient symptoms guess what they do they
do disregard the patient results and go
with their own instincts about what is
going on in the page
result report format is also a challenge
we know that there are labs lab
variation in normal range and report
formats lab report report format is
difficult to understand and I want to
point out the last bullet not enough
information in the lab report we also
asked them whether too much information
was a challenge and they said that not
enough information was more of a
challenge than too much so if you're
going to err on the side of not enough
or too much err on the side of too much
because they would prefer to have too
much rather than not enough some of the
responses that we got are listed here a
universal format simple and easy
structure and dispensing with the
results and not time consuming will be
extremely helpful I hate getting a three
page printout with only a couple of
lines of actual results now I'm going to
share with you about methods that they
found were helpful before I do I would
like to ask another question to do a
poll and it is what is the reason to
communicate with the lab what is the
most frequent reason physicians
communicate with laboratory professional
preliminary result information seeking
technical assistance regarding sample
collection assistance would follow up
testing status of missing results
getting close to time I might cut it off
that I appreciate all the voters a few
more coming in okay we're gonna close
the poll great so yes ask a laboratory
oh that's the wrong one let's close that
status of missing results that's right
71 percent we're going to go to the next
slide so as you know reasons physicians
communicate with laboratory
professionals most often status of
missing results preliminary results
information once again they go back to
we're the data generators less often
assistance regarding sample collection
and assistance with appropriate test
ordering I would like to point out
assistance with appropriate test
ordering that was the lowest percentage
reported for helpfulness unfortunately
they don't look to us to help them with
test ordering but assistance regarding
sample collection they found that was
the highest percentage reported for
helpfulness they know we know what type
of tube to use that I call us we can
tell them what color tube to use and how
to collect the sample we do a great job
with that and they find that very very
helpful but least often they ask us
about assistance with follow-up testing
once again they don't look to us to help
them with test selection and medical
opinion results was also least often we
did learn some things from the physician
focus groups that were heartwarming
here's some quotes you don't talk to a
radiologist or pharmacist and a
you talked to a colleague you talked to
a lab it's a black box I don't think
about calling the clinical pathologist
they have not made themselves available
to help me I don't know who they are for
radiology it's different I know my
radiologists and I have a personal
relationship with that person so I call
him and say this is what I'm thinking is
this the right test but it wasn't all
bad we did find several of the
physicians had the same idea that's in
this third quote but if it's an
interpretation or discrepancy then I
just call Bob who's in charge of the lab
a good guy and he knows everything so if
we could all become Bob then that would
be very helpful to the clinicians we
found that when clinicians had a
relationship with a professional in the
lab they call them a lot they utilize
that person so if we could become that
person that Bob I think then we would be
able to break down some of the barriers
between the lab and the clinicians so
what do they do and what are the methods
that we can provide them that would be
helpful I'm going to go to the
whiteboard to show you that reflex
testing trending interpreted comments
we're all very useful once again
usefulness is very or extremely useful
and in this the available is the percent
of position said yes these were
available so these three things were
very available and very useful but i'd
like to point out on this slide cpoe
with electronic suggestions was very
available very useful but it was not
very available it was the least
available of all of the things that we
asked him at this time of the survey so
it's very helpful but it was
not available but over on the right-hand
side CPOE without electronic suggestions
was available but it was the least
useful and that's computerized physician
order entry if it's just available for
ordering and it doesn't provide any help
it is not very helpful so we're hoping
that this will be an alert to help us
move to the next level where we can have
those type of supports that do have
electronic suggestions we analyzed some
of the comments from the survey and
sixteen percent of the comments
recommended improvements were based on
clinical decision support and electronic
tools one of the quotes I'm sure Mr
guidelines diagnostic algorithms pop ups
ranching to more information will become
a huge in the next ten years a uniform
compatible transferable searchable EMR
will be most important so at the time of
the survey clinicians did find that
collation decision support tools and
electronic tools they thought would be
helpful to them so what can we do some
solutions continue to provide what is
useful i mentioned trending interpreted
comments reflex testing they're
available and very useful also improve
clarity and consistency of ordering
systems so that they are easy to use for
the clinician also reporting systems
they should be easy to see the results
it so that they can understand what
their next step should be with the
patient so improve availability of CPOE
with electronic suggestions improve
availability of the other items that
they said that we're not very available
but we're very useful such as electronic
prompts test characteristics they like
to know what is the characteristic of
the test before they or them a dedicated
laboratory phone
we did find that if they could get to a
person in the lab that could answer the
question it was very helpful many of
them said that they don't call the lab
because they get put on hold or bounced
around and never get a person also
algorithms were also very very useful
but not very available at this time
another poll question see if I can get
to it what we're going to do is this one
is not coming up so what I'm going to do
is go ahead with the next slide but what
I'd like for you to do i'm going to give
you my email that's going to be at the
end of this webinar and if you would
like to let me know about your
institutions and whether you are
offering computerized physician order
entry with electronic suggestions that
would be very helpful we'll go to the
next slide we're going to talk about
decoding laboratory test names is
another project we have with click and
we have a publication out once again in
an internal medicine journal this time
the Journal of general internal medicine
and it's titled decoding laboratory test
names a major challenge to appropriate
patient care I will tell you about what
is in this particular journal but you
can get the free version downloaded at
the website at the bottom of the page
it's led by this project is led by Lisa
pass a month and Jim Mizell their goal
is to demonstrate the complexity of test
selection we all know that there are no
standardized test names for laboratory
tests so therefore we can have a
multiplicity of names for the same test
such as i have here for hepatitis B also
they can be very complex for example
rheumatoid factor is not specific for
rheumatoid arthritis so we don't have
any standardized mechanisms to make it
where there's one test so when the
physician was to order the test they
know what the name of the test is what
they did in this project is developed
flow chart and tables to demonstrate the
complexity of vitamin D as an example
and the breadth of the problem which is
not only in specialty areas but in
commonly ordered tests and also the
depth of the problem using coagulation
as an example now we are going to have
another poll question this is how many
different test names are there for
vitamin D one defined six to ten eleven
to fifteen or more than 15 and we're
going to give you some time for this
pole and then I'll close it and we
appreciate you voting it gives us some
ideas about what's going on in your area
okay looks like we're about finished ok
we're going to as you see you reported
125 test names for vitamin D most of you
split that between one to five and six
to ten and no 98 nine point eight
percent said more than 15 i'm going to
show you on the next slide the number of
names for vitamin D that are available
you were right but typically there are
only two meaning that there are two
different types of tests that you
usually conduct in the lab but sometimes
the physician sees all these different
names based on what lab they use and it
can be quite complicated so there are on
this slide 19 different names for
options for vitamin D and you can
imagine a clinician is only want to pick
a vitamin D test to order one to help
his elderly female patient to see
whether she's at risk for osteoporosis
and then they have to figure out which
tests to order so it can be quite
confusing I mentioned that we put
together some commonly ordered tests to
show you that it is a problem not only
with commonly ordered tests but also
within specialties but this shows you
that even a complete blood count with
differential can be confusing I will
share with you that some of the
physicians have told us in the focus
groups that they don't have a problem
ordering laboratory tests they'll tell
you why are you asking us about this
because they typically order 20 tests
they said we're comfortable with
ordering about 20 different tests that
are in their norm
experience for the day but if they get
outside of that 20 is where it does
become complicated for example many of
them have told us that we don't have a
problem with ordering coagulation tests
which is my next slide coagulation just
we don't have a problem ordering we
order everything on the menu so if we
could help them with which specific test
to order I think we would be doing a
better job for lab utilization at one
time the coagulation specialist did get
together and they standardized the
factor so that made it with faster
numbers to make it a little more
consistent but we still have a problem
with too many tests names even in
specialty areas this slide demonstrates
what you might have to go through in
your lis system if you're getting a new
electronic health record you're going to
have to math to all these different
names and as you see the very first is
the very top is a one-to-one correlation
and then you get one to two and then
many to one and then down at the bottom
is many to many so this becomes quite
complicated I will tell you that one of
the physicians Jim Mizell who works on
this project use this demonstration in
this particular slide to share with his
electronic health record experts to show
them what he wanted to have done when
they were mapping their lab tests for
their new EHR so maybe you can use it as
well some potential solutions to this
problem could be using something like
probably meant some type of name lab
test for example a set of criteria could
be established that could include
conditional rules for example if
ordering tests athan test b is more
likely than Tessie
frequency if a1 C or hba1c is more
likely to mean a 1h a1c then h1n1 in
other words it becomes something that is
programmed into the system so that you
could pick up the right test instead of
the wrong test accuracy actually typed
the way it's meant so this is all to
help with test ordering through the
different complicated set of tests
nomenclature another solution could be
that it could be a dynamic learning
system i mentioned that we are getting
new lab tests on the market every day we
have over 3,000 available today this
system would need to accommodate new
tests without it always being having to
be reprogrammed this should sound pretty
familiar to you if you type some
examples from this manuscript into an
internet search engine you will find
that it offers correct spelling and list
of synonyms so search engine technology
is available for us when we searched on
the internet to help us get to the right
search so why can't we use this type of
technology to help clinicians get to the
right test that they want to order
another project is diagnostic algorithms
led by Michael a Posada and Marissa
Marquis with this project we were going
to develop algorithms for selected
scenarios and then information
technology tools based on those
algorithms so to develop algorithms we
had three clinical pathologist help us
with some particular specialty types of
patients those with prolonged partial
thromboplastin time and normal prothom
and time and they worked on the testing
scenario related only to that type of
patient so that a physician would know
what tests to order and how to manage
their patients that have this particular
set of testing circumstances this
article has been published and it's in
this online library if you would like to
see it please go there it's free the
second thing that we worked on was IT
tools I have to share with you I showed
you a picture of our work group at our
face-to-face meeting that we have in
Atlanta every year we ask the work group
what would you like to see happen this
next year that would make you say a year
from now you were successful if you
accomplish this particular task and dr.
miss Marissa Marquis raised her hand and
said I would like us to develop a
smartphone mobile application for these
algorithms I thought Oh Julie you work
at CDC we published MMWR articles we
published guidelines we help people with
immunizations we don't have a group of
IT people sitting around like it other
IT companies like Apple and Google and
sitting around working on IT solutions
but I looked at Marissa and I said
Marissa that's a great idea I'll write
it down well I came back to CDC and
found out that yes we had just initiated
a group of IT experts to help with these
types of things we worked with them
through an innovation award that we won
because of our proposal CDC funded this
particular work internally and we now
have what's called the PTT advisor and
it's an app with algorithms for the
isolated PTT what this particular app
does and it's available i'll show you
the website and the the way you can get
this particular application but it takes
this complicated set of algorithms and
this is one of the algorithms that is
published in the journal article but it
takes it and turns it into a step by
up walkthrough for the clinician so that
clinician doesn't have to pull out a big
piece of paper and try to find out where
they are they can use their mobile
application which we are finding that
clinicians do more frequently now so
this is a screenshot from the PTT
advisor and the first question does the
patient have prolonged PTT and normal PT
so if you answer yes you go through the
series of the algorithm and you end up
with a recommendation this is another
screenshot and at the bottom of the page
you'll see down at the bottom that there
are some menu bars those menu bars help
you at the bottom of screen whether you
want to go back go to the next screen go
the last screen restart or at number
five here we've showed you that's an
evaluation review in other words this is
a complicated algorithm if you want to
find out well maybe forgot what question
I answered and how I answered it it will
give you all the questions and your
answers so if you want to change an
answer you can click on a button to
change the answer but it will warn you
in case you did that accidentally which
I'm not good with IT so I have a problem
with technology sometimes I click where
I'm not supposed to but this particular
one allows you to say okay I do want to
change and then it will go back to a
different part of the tree and allow you
to go down a different set of algorithms
if you have an iPhone we don't have this
available on the other I on the other
smartphones at this time but if you have
an iPhone you can use this quick read
code to download the PTT advisor or go
to the apple apple itunes store and you
can download it and use it you if you're
a physician out there in the audience
you can use this and help yourselves as
well as other other your physicians or
if you're in the lab you may want to use
it and share it with your clinician
clients as well
here's another poll question and I will
bring this up do you think clinicians in
your healthcare institution would use
mobile applications to assist them with
test utilization I hope that will find
this one is an easy question as well but
I do see that there are some that would
not bet this is very helpful because
we're looking at a lot of different IT
solutions to help clinicians I'm going
to let this go a little bit longer okay
so we're going to close the poll and and
push the results out great so the
majority of you did say yes but I'm very
interested many of you said no we are
also looking into taking the algorithms
and putting them directly into the
workflow of the clinician so example
would be the clinician is sitting at the
computer to order a test that is when
the information from the algorithm would
come up and it would be during the
normal time there interacting with the
computer so they would not have to pull
a smartphone or mobile app out and this
would be possible now that we are going
to more electronic and emrs EHRs the
data that we have in these algorithms
could be pulled into this particular
type of application so that the
clinician could have the information
right there in front of them but thank
you for for your answers I'm going to
now focus on the last part of our talk
and its own medical student education to
pass most medical students must know
what damaged heart tissue looks like
under the microscope after a heart
but not what blood tests are needed to
diagnose a heart attack if I'm in the ER
with a suspect heart attack I don't want
them to have to do a biopsy to find out
whether I'm having a heart attack I want
them to know what lab tests to order so
this study was led by Brian Smith and
John hick nur and it's a survey of us
medical schools their goal was to raise
awareness about the gaps and us medical
school curricula focused for laboratory
medicine training and determine the
amount of instruction about test
selection and results interpretation so
they surveyed all US medical schools a
sample question there's two on the
screen in the preclinical portion of
your school's curriculum does your
school have a separate distinct course
or is it integrated into the other
courses another question please estimate
the number of hours of instruction each
student receives in your required
laboratory medicine curriculum so the
results 75% of schools responded which
is good and very good is that
eighty-four percent reported some
coursework in laboratory medicine but
only nine percent reported that it was a
separate and distinct course the median
number of hours for required lectures
were also minimal 84 laboratory medicine
and only two more for transfusions so
their hours for lab training in medical
school was 10 hours and if you compare
that to anatomic pathology and this was
a survey that was done in another study
so we didn't compare this is not apples
to apples but it gives you an idea the
anatomic pathology there are sixty one
two three hundred and two hours of
training in medical school
but we don't know how to use test to
diagnose a heart attack so what can we
do add more lab centric course material
define laboratory science and
professional roles for users of lab
tests but if we do these things we have
to be cautious what course material will
be eliminated if lab material is added
and who can we work with to help us
accomplish these things so in closing I
want to offer you some ideas of what you
can look at in your own health care
facility you can continue to provide
what is useful trending interpreted
comments reflex testing find out if your
facility has this and if they don't see
if you can implement it also find out
whether you have CPOE with electronic
suggestions so that when the clinician
is ordering a lab test help box comes up
to tell them about the test
characteristics or some information
about the test so they will know whether
that test is appropriate for their
patient electronic prompts test
characteristics information if you can a
dedicated laboratory font phone line was
found to be very very useful I mentioned
our projects in the area developing
algorithms you probably could develop
algorithms in your own environment you
could possibly find out what are the
areas of need in your own health care
institution you could look and see our
clinicians ordering every type of
coagulation tests on the panel at one
time or are they being more selective in
deciding what tests they should order
maybe you could help them with certain
types of tests ordering if you find out
that they are having problems ordering
and there is a problem with lab test
utilization in a certain area also we
found to improve clarity and consistency
of your ordering systems also in
providing results in a manner that is
easily busy
nowadays we are moving to electronic
mechanisms that I think results
reporting is going to be a new way for
us to be able to highlight what are the
most important things that we want the
clinician to see in this lab report we
don't want to just provide a bunch of
language that's kind of hard to find the
actual information that they need to act
on and maybe with particular types of
colors and graphs there may be
mechanisms for us to provide results in
a more meaningful way to help clinicians
interpret the results in closing I would
like to offer two quotes from recent
articles focusing on ordering the right
test during initial evaluation as
opposed to reducing repeat testing may
have the greater impact on reducing
errors and improving care primary care
providers should have convenient access
to laboratory physicians to assist in
laboratory test ordering and
interpretation now I would like to offer
that I think we should go beyond
physicians many of us in the lab or
professionals and we could provide
assistance to clinicians so I think you
could look at this and determine whether
there is someone in the lab that is
capable and has time to be able to help
with this particular set of tests
ordering challenges and test result
interpretation challenges knowing is not
enough we must apply willing is not
enough we must do I challenge you to
take at least one thing that you've
learned from the talk today and try and
implement it in your own environment if
you don't think that any of these items
that I've suggested could be helpful at
least meet with clinicians those who are
ordering tests from the lab and find out
what are some of their challenges you
can use
our survey and the results from our
survey to help post some questions to
ask them maybe your system and situation
are better than many that we found
around the country which would be
wonderful and finally I have my email
address here on the slide and I would
really like to hear from you if there is
something that you would like to share
with me about a positive situation that
you have that was able to improve lab
test utilization or if you have some
suggestions for what we could share with
others we appreciate your time today and
with that I'm going to go to questions
and answers questions the first one I
believe can i reuse the information on
the book I need permission I think
they're asking can they use what we
provided today and yes that that would
yes that would be perfectly fine I
believe all of this is available to the
public is standardization of diagnostic
kit names being done in collaboration
with kit manufacturers I have to tell
you I work at CDC and our sister agency
is the FDA and we have had many
conversations with them because they are
the ones that approve what tests go on
the market and they approve the product
inserts that have the test names and all
about the test and at this time they are
not willing to limit the types of names
based on what comes in so we don't
really have a good mechanism right now
to standardize test names but what we
could work on or possibly the mechanisms
i mentioned to have IT tools to help
with test selection and also if there
are areas that could be standardized
easily or be able to be linked or
connected such as i mentioned in when
you're doing your program
where you could have a one type of lab
tests name that could be mapped to many
different other ones then clinician
would only have to order or no one named
but then it would go to different test
names maybe that would be helpful as
well can you give permission to put some
information on my website please send me
an email and what we can do is I can
find out about how we can work that out
I am even though I work with great IT
people at CDC I have to use them as the
way to to get things accomplished but I
do believe that what we have to offer at
CDC we would love to have you posted on
your website so please send me some
information about how we can do that and
if there are some connections between
what you're doing we may be able to
provide a link from our website to your
website as well so if you have something
that you think would be valuable in
posting of course we do have to go
through and a very detailed CDC review
before we post things but we are looking
for good models of practice good things
that we can share whether their
education programs their ways to have
good algorithms that have been developed
new types of clinical decision support
tools we're interested in those types of
items and we can share them as well
let's see if there there's yes he
already responded I don't believe I see
any more questions and we are about out
of time so with that I want to thank you
all for your time today and I do hope
that our paths will cross in the future
if not then I appreciate your time and
you have a great day and I wish you good
luck in improving lavatory utilization
in your own healthcare facility goodbye
you